so we're not gonna give away too much
but everybody is buzzing about Aria Aria
really is
but yes you all sophie Turner had a
major shout out to her Thrones little
sister but SNL's Leslie Jones really
lost it live tweeting as she watched
from home what do you say to the god of
death I wouldn't kill him until you see
the next one
this is behind-the-scenes footage of
last night's epic 82 minute battle the
HBO sequence made cinematic history for
the longest battle scene ever that
record had belonged to the Lord of the
Rings the two towers for this 40 minute
or seen episode threes spectacle of Fire
and Ice was shot over 11 weeks of a
grueling ice-cold night shoots star
Emilia Clarke said it was 14 below for
some of her scenes it's too cold snow
when it's too cold to snow you know you
go in trouble how grueling was it for
you guys to film that battle it was in
the dead of Northern Irish winter they
were night shoots they start being
constantly jet backed it's really cold
but there were a lot of complaints that
the episode was too dark and hard to see
including this meme with the caption me
after turning off every light in our
apartment is still struggling to see and
this tweet next week the battle to
rescue the lighting equipment from
Cersei and for those who didn't make it
out alive well we won't spoil that let's
just say it's gut-wrenching we've been
with these characters for so many years
we've been like - Helen back with them
[Music]
[Applause]